Hindu weddings in India are absolutely lavish events.
You will be overwhelmed by the colors, the food, and the warmth of the people.
Weddings take place over several days.
There are religious ceremonies intermixed with fireworks and parades.
Weddings are a chance for the families to display their wealth.
At the Mehndi ceremony, the bride is covered in turmeric paste and she is decorated with henna.
At the Varmala ceremony,...
...bride and groom place garlands around each other's necks hampered by teasing friends.
The Mandap ceremony takes place under a canopy of four pillars...
...that stand for the four parents who give their blessings.
At the Vidai ceremony, the bride leaves her house for the last time...
...and casts rice and coins toward her old home, in a gesture of thanks to her parents.
Unless you are lucky enough to get an invite from a local, you could contact a government tourist office.